if you had to get the shop on the show
how would you like to meet your maker
heroically I'd like to go over swinging
I would like him to go out and I'd
really kick ass fake something
outrageous like flamboyant I like the
idea of getting Burton white black oil
but like really like like like I kind of
like Madonna s kind of like stage show
den yeah yeah very whimsical every time
we see him I'm like if I don't doubt
July and he just laughs this is little
giggle and I'm like no you can't do that
I think Barrack should fight it dragon
fire with fire flaming sword it gets a
flaming dragon yeah and you know I could
shield he could protect himself I think
he'd be pretty good riding into battle
with a double-edged axe in one hand and
a scream of glory in my throat into an
army of wildlings I think something epic
with an axe I'd like to just go very
quickly very non painfully
being beheaded would be pretty bad I
think I would like someone to rip the
Moscow and stop me in my face
I'd like to die fighting an army of
White Walkers yeah that's just a huge
action scene would be nice I'll enjoy
that getting his head chopped off - I
know I know why not having head on a
pike
I met a fight with a dragon it'd be
great what am I losing to a dragon yet
use any face a screaming like axe fight
with OSHA that Center is a lot of fun to
work with and she's completely mad and I
reckon that OSHA can have a very violent
side we should come out so they can now
be a fun way to die home drawn and
quartered because I've never seen
anybody hung drawn and quartered if a
fighting man's gotta go he should go
fighting it would have to be something
spectacular
maybe burned today drowned in sand I
like human burial you know like that's
great I don't think Jack and could die
could he he could just change into
someone else couldn't accept the best
way to die on this show is to be burnt
alive by drag and pushed off the wall
and then getting eaten by the crows I
think I'd love to be so thrown off a
cliff or something and then get eaten by
dragons but of natural causes sitting on
a throne with Richard Madden in my arm
in an embrace
you don't kiss maybe yeah
like a lingering death kiss